hi guys welcome to the just pearly songs
youtube channel
and today as usual i am going to be
reacting
to a rap song that i don't know
at all and that i don't understand i
gotta readjust you guys already know
i don't listen to rap i don't understand
rap but
i'm gonna analyze the lyrics for you
guys
before i begin don't forget to comment
like
and subscribe comment did i get the
analysis right did i get it wrong leave
a like and don't forget to subscribe
today the song i'm gonna do is little
baby
as real as it gets apparently this is
like a
a hip new song i don't know you guys
gotta keep me updated
i just took a nap and now i'm back so
that's why
i might look a little disoriented but
i'm about to react to this video now
okay
[Music]
okay i put down my glock but i picked up
a stick
[Music]
i i don't know what that means is that
wrong
is that wrong i don't know okay so i
think that's a gut
i have put down my glock but i picked up
a stick
did he put down one type of gun and pick
up another type of gun
okay so that this is that part's really
simple so he's saying
that his people so maybe like his family
the people where he's from
are proud of him for where he's at and
he is as real as it's gonna get
[Music]
okay so he's saying he doesn't like to
wait he's impatient
i'm impatient too i'm like the most
impatient person i know
and he's also saying that he made a way
for
other people basically saying that
he made it easier for other people to
get to success because he was successful
[Music]
okay if anyone knows how to get rid of
this little corner thing
i like can't get rid of it okay so he's
saying he was born
into this stuff so i'm guessing he's
talking about like the rap gang and he
grew
up with felons
so he's just saying like he had a hard
upbringing i want to say
okay what reaches
[Music]
i don't really have to talk about step
it sounds like step into something
illegal is that when you
kill somebody so i don't really have to
talk about
killing that would make sense because
his people
don't get caught when it happens so it
sounds like he's maybe killed some
people
and he doesn't get caught when it
happens
[Music]
so i think when he says i can promise
we're clapping he's also talking about
killing
i really think this is all like threats
[Music]
okay so he's saying got no love for a
hoe i'm not passionate so he's saying
he's not trying to date a hoe and i get
it you know
you can't you can't date girls that are
for the street i get it
okay
okay so he's saying that other people
don't have money
but he does so he's saying what's the
most you've ever spent
i've spent a lot of money but what have
you spent
[Music]
i just want to know
where they shoot these videos
okay so i don't know why like in a lot
of rap videos
they'll just be like with their friends
in a random like house just like
chilling and like going like this
i don't have that many friends like
okay now he's what is he doing
another scene
all this [ __ ] started off in the kitchen
what happens in the kitchen
show me one something show me once i was
paying attention you don't have to tell
them things more than once
good thing quick learner that's good as
the trenches they gonna say i'm the
realest official the difference between
me and [ __ ] i'm rich when i get off my
insta
get them killed by the night for a 60 i
sent that i can't even risk it i just
want to be finished but i'm steadily
winning
[Music]
i'm rich when i get off my instagram so
does that mean he gets like
paid promotions and stuff off of
instagram
that's probably what that means
okay so he's saying in his city he's the
richest one
he's the most successful we stand a
successful king
that's good we had two or three [ __ ]
still dead friendship defense watch send
a disney hide and get your man shot
so he's saying if you diss him you are
going to get your man
shot not a good thing that's not what we
want [ __ ] play but they know we gonna
air it out
okay so i think he's saying first he
said that he flew
a girl and her friend out so he
is flying out pretty women um because
he's successful
second thing he's saying is that other
people put their heads down when they
see them
i think this is referring to something
with not wanting to get shot they talk
about getting shot a lot in this
so i'm saying they don't want to get
shot if the music don't crack
really living what i rap 250 at the trap
if i say it is a fact
you was
okay you're a killer on an app so i
think he's saying you talk but
you don't have any action you're just a
killer on an app
guess who put us on the map so i'm
assuming
someone put them on the map
three cars ten straps three cars ten
guns three cars ten guns
i get it i get it okay
[Music]
[Music]
same thing he's just saying i made the
way for you guys
you guys are kind of like chicken
don't play with me i think the main
point of the song is really little
babies just saying don't play with me
i'm real i'm cool um
yeah i'm in terms of the song
i'm gonna give it like a six out of ten
i liked it i was bopping my head
one too many guns for me personally but
i'm not gonna
deduct that from the song because
there's guns in a lot of songs that's
cool
secondly i think the second main message
is
he he's just letting people know that
he's real
and i know that just means you're really
cool so
let me know in the comments did i get it
right did i get it wrong
sorry i'm a little hazy today i just
woke up from a nap
it was a good nap i'm not even gonna lie
but
let me know in the comments am i right
am i wrong give me a like
subscribe to the channel don't forget
i'm
i'm gonna talk to you guys next time